[Musik]
historischer Moment in Großbritannien 70
Jahre nach der Queen wird ihr Sohn
Charles III in der alt erwürdigen
Westminster Abbey zum König gekrönt
Gott save the king
mit den Insignien der Macht steigt
Charles III in die goldene staatskutsche
zur krönungsprozession begeistert
empfangen von 10.000 Schaulustigen
ja und auch dieses Bild hat eine lange
Tradition die Begrüßung der Menge vom
Balkon des Buckingham Palace
und dazu gehört mit Queen Camilla auch
eine neue Königin seit 70 Jahren hat es
eine solche Krönungszeremonie nicht mehr
gegeben Millionen Zuschauer verfolgten
sie vor dem Fernseher 10.000er an der
prozessionsstrecke in London Andreas
Stamm fast den historischen Tag zusammen
ein Moment der unter die Haut ging gott
schütze den König
[Musik]
Glanz und Gloria auf britisch wie es nur
wenige inszenieren können und wollen
ein religiöser Moment manchmal gar zu
sensibel für die Augen und Ohren der
Welt wie die Salbung mit Olivenöl aus
dem Heiligen Land
es endet mit dem Moment für die Ewigkeit
niemand hat länger auf den Thron
gewartet als Charles III
die Krönung eine fast 1000 Jahre alte
Zeremonie an manchen Stellen
modernisiert zum ersten Mal etwa durften
auch Vertreter anderer
Glaubensrichtungen Teil des Gottesdienst
sein
2200 Gäste Prominenz und Politiker aus
aller Welt verdiente Bürger Royals
deutlich weniger als vor 70 Jahren
gedacht auch als ein Zeichen von
Sparsamkeit in wirtschaftlich
schwierigen Zeiten ein Zeichen ist die
Krönung dennoch geschätzt mehr als 200
Millionen Pfund kostet die goldene
Kutsche auch an militärischen Ehren
wurde nicht gespart wie auch bei stolz
und Begeisterung der vielen
hunderttausend entlang der
prozessionsstrecke
großartig unsere Tradition ein
Königspaar zu haben tut uns einfach gut
was für eine Atmosphäre hier die alle
zusammenkommen ein toller Tag
das ist überhaupt nicht zu protzig
Unsinn wir lieben die königliche Familie
keine Liebe hier am Rande kommt es zu
Festnahmen von Umweltschützern und
antimonarchisten ungewollt
undemokratisch und zu teuer deren
krönungsfazit
eine Mehrheit unterstützt die Monarchie
noch immer auch weil es die meisten
Medien tun aber selbst die Unterstützer
76% von ihnen erklären dass es Reformen
braucht was zumindest zeigt es gibt
Redebedarf und das mit dem System der
Monarchie grundsätzlich was nicht stimmt
nicht nur hier in London auch in anderen
Städten kam es zu kleineren Protesten
ein Makel den aus Sicht des gekrönten
Königspaars solche Bilder vergessen
machen dürften
es mag Kritik geben doch die Erkenntnis
des Tages dem Regen trotzen und zu
Monarchie stehen ist noch immer very
british äußerst britisch
noch mal auf diesen Tag geschaut mit
Hilfe Petersen vor dem Buckingham Palace
in London Hilfe zu sehen waren heute
überwiegend jubelnde Massen im Herzen
Londons spiegelt das die Stimmung im
gesamten Land
ja jede Menge ich sag mal verregnete
Royale Freude in Londons Zentrum hier
hinter mir am Buckingham Palast ist es
immer noch im Gange ich weiß nicht genau
warum denn die Gründung ist ja schon
wirklich jetzt ein paar Stunden her die
Briten sind stolz auf ihre
tausendjährige Geschichte auf ihre
krönungsgeschichte aber man muss auch
sagen wir haben es eben im Stück gehört
zwei Drittel der Briten stehen der Sache
kritisch gegenüber fragt man sie gucken
Sie die Krönung sagen sie nein
wahrscheinlich nicht oder auf gar keinen
Fall einig sind sich alle darin dass das
lange Wochenende gut ist denn am Montag
gibt es ein extra Feiertag was wird King
Charles denn anders machen als seine
Mutter die Verstorbene Queen Elizabeth
ja der Monarch die Monarchin ist zu
politischer Neutralität verpflichtet und
die Queen war unfassbar neutral Prinz
Charles oder König Charles der als Prinz
Charles ja wirklich eine lange lange
Zeit auf den Thron gewartet hat hat ganz
viel Stiftungen und sich um Themen
gekümmert die man durchaus einer
politischen Haltung zuordnen könnte
Umwelt Nachhaltigkeit mit seinem
Princess Trust einer Stiftung die sich
um benachteiligte Jugendliche kümmert
auch sozialpolitische Themen der König
wird gebeten von der Regierung auf
Staatsbesuche zu gehen das heißt da ist
er so ein bisschen kann er so ein
bisschen soft Diplomatie machen aber ein
eigenes politisches Profil ist ihm
eigentlich nicht erlaubt danke und Grüße
ins verregnete London Hilfe vielen Dank
und wenn Sie noch mehr Krönung schauen
möchten dann empfehlen wir Ihnen das
zdf-spezial gibt es direkt nach uns und
auch in der ZDF heute App gibt es ein
breites Angebot unter anderem ein
Porträt des neuen Königs und sein langer
Weg auf den Thron
vom Vereinigten Königreich nach Bayern
wo die CSU quasi heute ihre eigene
kleine Krönung zelebrierte für die
Landtagswahl in 5 Monaten kürten die
Christsozialen heute Markus Söder
einstimmig zu ihrem Spitzenkandidaten
über bayerische Ansprüche ampelkritik
und Vorschusslorbeeren für den
wiedergewählten Spitzenkandidaten
berichtet Alexander Pool
gut ich stimme auch für mich sagt Markus
Söder und sorgt damit für den
einstimmigen Parteitagsbeschluss er ist
der Spitzenkandidat für die bayerische
Landtagswahl
ich gratuliere uns dazu ich bedanke mich
bei Euch so das redet zuvor anderthalb
Stunden lang eine Mischung aus
Programmatik und Attacke vor allem gegen
die Ampel vor allem gegen die Grünen
etwa zur verwandtenaffäre um
Staatssekretär Patrick reichen im
Bundeswirtschaftsministerium das ist
nichts anderes als grüne Korruption habe
ich muss gleichen entlassen sonst ist
die verwandtenaffäre gleichen eine
Affäre Habeck oder zur Kernenergie und
deswegen ist und bleibt es ein
fundamentaler weitreichender Fehler für
die Wirtschaft und für die Bürger
Deutschlands die Kernkraftwerke
abzuschalten stehende Applaus für einen
Parteichef mit dem längst nicht alle in
der CSU warm werden zu oft hatte Söder
in der Vergangenheit Positionen
gewechselt und so seiner Partei und
ihren Wählern viel Geduld abverlangt im
Jahr der Landtagswahl aber setzt die CSU
auf das Zug fährt dass sie hat ich
glaube er hat gelernt dass es nicht nur
eine One-Man-Show ist sondern dass wir
als Team als CSU gemeinsam ein starkes
Team sind und nur gemeinsam stark auch
gewinnen können selbstverständlich wird
sie Alternativen geben aber er hat
seitdem Amt ist überzeugt vor allem
seine ständige Präsenz hat die Kritik an
Söder leiser werden lassen ob das bis
zur Wahl im Oktober so bleibt hängt auch
davon ab wie sich die Umfragen in den
nächsten Monaten entwickeln
des Bundeswirtschaftsministerium hat
über Jahre den Auftritt deutscher
Waffenhersteller auf der weltgrößten
Waffenmesse in Las Vegas mitfinanziert
das haben gemeinsame Recherchen von
ZDF-Magazin Royal und Berliner
Tagesspiegel ergeben der letzte Auftritt
im Januar diesen Jahres war aber noch
von der alten Regierung unter dem CDU
geführten Ministerium veranlasst worden
künftig werde es keine Unterstützung
mehr geben teilte das Habeck Ministerium
jetzt auf Anfrage mit
deutschland braucht Partner und Konzepte
für die Energieversorgung der Zukunft
auch deswegen besucht Bundeskanzler
Scholz am Ende seiner Afrika-Reise Kenia
ein Land das bei der Nutzung
erneuerbarer Energien schon weit
vorangekommen ist hier wurden Ende 2022
die fossilen Energien wie Gas oder Öl
nur noch für knapp 20% der
Stromerzeugung benötigt den großen Teil
gewinnt Kenia aus Erdwärme Wasserkraft
Wind oder Sonnenenergie Susann von
Lojewski berichtet
zumindest ein kurzer Blick auf die
herrliche kenianische Landschaft war dem
Bundeskanzler heute vergönnt Olaf Scholz
am sogenannten Great Rift Valley dem
großen Grabenbruch durch die tektonische
erdplattenverschiebung ist Geothermie
hier leicht zugänglich wir werden das
Land dabei unterstützen und auch viele
andere Nachbarstaaten Kenias die diesen
Weg beschreiten worden wollen
gleichzeitig ist das eine Möglichkeit
neben der Stromproduktion auch
Wasserstoff zu produzieren Kenia gilt in
Sachen grüne Energie als Vorreiter nicht
nur in Afrika schon vor Jahren hat die
Regierung die politische Entscheidung
getroffen ausschließlich auf eigene
nachhaltige Ressourcen zu setzen so wird
im Great Drift Valley das größte
geothermiewerk Afrikas Betrieben beim
Aufbau hat die deutsche Förderbank KfW
mit günstigen Krediten über 215
Millionen Euro geholfen jetzt geht's ja
insgesamt um Geschwindigkeit ich bin
deshalb sehr
beeindruckt ja sein Ziel von 90 auf 100%
erneuerbarer Stromproduktion zu kommen
bis 2030 noch schneller erreichen will
Technologie und Ingenieurwissen aus
Deutschland wird auch im Werk eukaria
eingesetzt eine Zusammenarbeit im Kampf
gegen den Klimawandel gestern
Migrationspolitik und
wirtschaftsperspektiven heute noch
einmal grün viel Energie Olaf Scholz
holt bei seinem Besuch besonders eines
hervor deutschland braucht Kenia um
gemeinsam globale Herausforderungen zu
bestehen Deutschland könne von Kenia
lernen so der Kanzler vor seiner Abreise
weiter erneuerbare Energien auszubauen
und die Erschließung der Geothermie
voranzutreiben
seit dem Einmarsch in die Ukraine gab es
in Russland schon mehrere Anschläge auf
Befürworter des Krieges jetzt traf es
den bekannten nationalistischen
Schriftsteller Sacher privi durch eine
Autobombe wurde sein Fahrer getötet ihn
selbst wurde verletzt der Schriftsteller
hatte schon vor Jahren für einen Angriff
auf die Ukraine geworben und dort auch
an der Seite pro russischer Separatisten
gekämpft
der Iran hat ein weiteres Todesurteil
vollstreckt hingerichtet wurde der
schwedisch iranische Staatsbürger Habib
scharf er soll an mehreren
Terroranschlägen beteiligt gewesen sein
Deutschland Bank weiter um den zum Tode
verurteilten Deutsch Iraner jumpsuitarat
Ende April hatte das Oberste Gericht das
Urteil bestellt
drei Wochen nach dem Beginn der Kämpfe
im Sudan gehen die Gefechte weiter
hunderttausende Menschen sind auf der
Flucht das flüchtlingswerk der Vereinten
Nationen rechnet mit
860.000 Flüchtlinge so eine vorläufige
Schätzung mehr als 120.000 Sudanesen
haben das Land schon verlassen knapp die
Hälfte nach Ägypten aus kostuhl und
Assuan wo die Menschen nach ihrer
schwierigen Flucht ankommen berichtet
jetzt gulineartei
eine lange Reihe von Bussen voller
geflüchtete sie warten auf die Fähre
annasia Stausee setzen Sie über nach
Ägypten
mehr als 53.000 Sudanesen retteten sich
bislang hierher sie mussten erleben wie
Menschen vor ihren Augen erschossen
wurden wie ihre Hauptstadt ausgeraubt
wurde
bald Hunger geben alles deutet darauf
hin die Lebensbedingungen sind extrem
hart geworden ist jetzt leer wie eine
Wüste
das war ihr zu Hause augenzeugen
berichten auch heute von Luftangriffen
und Schusswechsel
an der Grenze erwarten Ägyptens roter
Halbmond und das UN-Flüchtlingswerk Wald
noch mehr Busse viele brauchen Medizin
und psychologische Hilfe
die Leute müssen sich neues Leben
aufbauen die Leute haben teilweise gar
nichts mit und zugleich sehen wir dass
das was gerade an Hilfe geliefert wird
einfach nicht genug ist am Busbahnhof in
Assuan warten viele auf die Weiterreise
in nur drei Wochen hat sich ihr Leben
auf den Kopf gestellt
lass uns noch mehr ängstigte als die
Einschläge war dass die Paramilitärs
unsere Wohnhäuser stürmten es waren
nicht nur die Geschosse sondern dass wir
uns überfallen aber unsere Armee wird es
schaffen
ägyptische freiwillige verteile Essen an
die geflüchte in ihrer Heimat haben
Armee und Paramilitärs heute verkündet
sie wollten den Krieg nicht beenden
sondern nur eine humanitäre Feuerpause
verhandeln damit Zivilisten ihre Häuser
verlassen können und Hilfsgüter ins Land
kommen
wenn sie den Menschen im Sudan helfen
möchten so ginge es über das
Aktionsbündnis Katastrophenhilfe
iban.de
400-100 400 Stichwort ZDF Nothilfe Sudan
alle Infos dazu auch auf spenden.zdf.de
und auf der ZDF Textseite 89.0
um geflüchtete besser zu integrieren
sollten Sie einen schnelleren Zugang zum
Arbeitsmarkt bekommen das fordert der
Deutsche Städtetag außerdem müssten
Qualifikationen von geflüchteten viel
unbürokratischer anerkannt werden so
städtetagspräsident Markus Lewe in einem
Zeitungsinterview am 10 Mai treffen sich
Länder und Kommunen mit Bundeskanzler
Scholz zum sogenannten flüchtlingsgipfel
jetzt nach Kanada in der Provinz Alberta
im Westen des Landes in zahlreiche
Waldbrände außer Kontrolle geraten
einige Feuer erstreckten sich über
tausende Hektar berichten lokale Medien
ungewöhnlich hohe Temperaturen und
starker Wind fahren die Brände an mehr
als 20.000 Menschen mussten sich laut
Feuerwehr in Sicherheit bringen
so jetzt zum Sport und ja nach kleinen
Sensation im Tennis Katja allerdings
ATP-Masters in Madrid erreicht und das
obwohl er in der Qualifikation
eigentlich schon ausgeschieden war im
Halbfinale besiegte Stoff den
rosencharakter nach drei hart umkämpften
setzen
vergleichsweise gelassen nimmt er die
Operationen entgegen dabei ist Jan
Lennart Strumpf gerade etwas Einmaliges
gelungen den Russen Aslan karatev seinen
Bezwinger in der Qualifikation hat er
beim zweiten Aufeinandertreffen in
Madrid geschlagen erstmals ist ein Lucky
Looser ins Finale eines solch
hochkarätigen Turniers eingezogen auch
ein verlorener erster Satz bringt den 33
Jahre alten Mann aus Warstein nicht aus
dem Konzept nicht nur sein harter
Aufschlag überzeugt auch sein variables
Spiel
Stoff braucht fünf Matchbälle dann aber
gewinnt er den entscheidenden dritten
Satz mit 6:40 Uhr im Ersten Masters
Finale seiner Karriere wartet mit den
jungen Spanier Carlos der derzeit wohl
formstärkste Spieler der Welt auf stuff
Triathletin Anne Haut hat dank einer
starken Laufleistung die European open
auf Ibiza gewonnen und auch Jan Frodeno
meldete sich dort nach langer
Verletzungspause beachtlich zurück nach
zwei Kilometern schwimmen 80,2 km auf
dem Rad und 17,8 Kilometer laufen kam er
als 4 ins Ziel jetzt aber schnurst zur
Fußball-Bundesliga und den Ergebnissen
vom 31 Spieltag Freiburg verliert gegen
Leipzig 0:1 Hoffenheim schlägt Frankfurt
3:1 auch Gladbach mit dem Heimsieg 2:0
gegen Bochum Augsburg gewinnt gegen
Union Berlin 1:0 Hertha besiegt
Stuttgart 2:1 am Abend und später
ausführlich im Aktuellen Sportstudio die
Partie Bremen gegen die Bayern und
bereits gestern zwei auswärtige Köln
gewinnt den Leverkusen 2:1 und Schalke
in Mainz 3 zu 2
in der Tabelle die Bayern vor Dortmund
Leipzig wieder auf einem Champions
League-Platz Union in Freiburg jetzt auf
vier und fünf keine Veränderung im
Vergleich zur Vorwoche auf dem Plätzen
sechs bis 14 das heißt auch das Gladbach
weiter die zweite Tabellenhälfte anführt
vor Köln und Bremen Schalke verlässt den
abstiegsdrang liegt jetzt auf Rang 15
ganz unten Stuttgart Bochum und weiter
die härter ja und alles und aktuellen
Spieltag natürlich im Aktuellen
Sportstudio von 23 Uhr an zu Gast sind
die Eishockey Nationalspieler Moritz
Müller und Nico Sturm vor der
anstehenden WM
die Spielerinnen vom FC Bayern München
sind drei Spieltage vor Schluss weiter
auf kurz Richtung Titel aber der 2:1
Sieg heute gegen die sgss Essen war er
zittert und er kämpft
Erleichterung bei den Bayern Sieg
gerettet denn nach dieser Notbremse in
der 59 minute waren die
meisterschaftsanwärterinnen nur noch zu
zehnt in der ersten Halbzeit gehen die
Bayern durch Lea Schiller in Führung
weil bei Lena Ostermeiers
Rettungsversuch der Ball schon mit
vollem Durchmesser hinter der Linie war
34 Minuten nur 4 Minuten später erhöhte
Lina magul zum 2:0 es scheint eine klare
Sache zu werden für die Münchnerinnen
nur zwei Minuten nach dem Platzverweis
gelingt Natascha Kowalski der
Anschlusstreffer zum 1 zu 2 Essen kämpft
noch um den Ausgleich aber vergeblich
das warst du hast aber noch was ja genau
danke Katja wir Enten quasi wie wir
begonnen haben nämlich mit dem
britischen Royals genauer gesagt mit der
Nummer vier in der Thronfolge und nennen
wir das was wir jetzt sehen mal
Erholungsphase Prinz Louis gerade fünf
Jahre alt schwer er müde von der langen
Krönungszeremonie und auch auf dem
Balkon zeigte sich der jüngste Sohn von
William und Kate relativ unbeeindruckt
von den royalen Feierlichkeiten
so das Wetter das bleibt wild im Westen
drohen kräftige Schauer und Gewitter
mehr gleich von Katja horneffer das
heute journal heute um 22:45 Uhr mit
Marietta Slomka das war's schönen
Samstag und gerne bis morgen
[Musik]
guten Abend turbulent ging es gestern
Richtung Wochenende mit kräftigen
Regenschauern und Gewittern sie sehen
die gelben Blitze die vor allen Dingen
über Baden-Württemberg und Bayern zogen
drei bis vier Zentimeter groß waren die
Hagelkörner Mitternacht waren dann die
Gewitter durch das dazugehörige tief
Xaver wird morgen Richtung Rumänien
ziehen und der Sonntag beginnt dank hoch
Tina erstmal recht freundlich dann kommt
das nächste Unwetter tief Jannes daran
heute Nacht ist es häufig klar den
Süddeutschland bildet sich Nebel an der
oder kann es noch leicht regnen und hier
im Westen tauchen schon neue Regenbogen
auf dort liegen die Temperaturen dabei
13 Grad deutlich kühler wird es auf
Rügen mit 4 Grad und morgen ist es im
Nordosten kühler als im Südwesten im
Nordosten steigen die Wetter 14 bis 17
im Südwesten auf 18 bis 24 Grad und
morgen Vormittag geht's erstmal mit viel
Sonnenschein hier z.B in Bayern los hier
im Nordosten sind die Wolkenfelder
erstmal Dichtung im Westen kommen schon
die ersten Regenfälle heran nachmittags
Bruder ist dann wieder der Atmosphäre es
gibt kräftige Schauer und Gewitter
freundlicher wird es dann Richtung
Berlin und Brandenburg und in den
nächsten Tagen geht es sehr wechselhaft
weiter schönes Wochenende